Do you read a newspaper every morning?
When I get up in the morning,...
...the very first thing I do is turn on my computer and look up the Internet sources up-to-date news.
It seems like more and more people don't feel the joy of picking up a newspaper in the morning.
When I was young, looking at my dad spreading a newspaper,...
...I thought it was a very cool thing to do, and I still think so.
Growing up mimicking my dad, I browse all the news headlines first,...
...and then read stories on politics or economics.
What about you, Alex, what kind of media tool do you use to get current issues?
I hear news from the radio in the morning,...
...and when I get to my workplace, I also look on the Internet, just like you,...
...and then usually I talk about the stuff mentioned in the news with my colleagues during coffee breaks and lunchtime.
At night, when I get home, I watch news on TV.
Wow, after listing all of these things I do every day,...
...I do pay a lot of attention to what's happening around the world.
Let me ask you this.
Do you believe that what's being said in the news is always true?